- [Rosie] Hello, grammarians, hello David.
- [David] Hello, Rosie!
- [Rosie] So today,
we're going to talk about
understatement and overstatement.
- [David] And I could not be more excited.
This is like the coolest thing
that's happened to me all week!
- [Rosie] Oh my gosh.
Really? (laughs)
- [David] Uh, uh, uh, no.
I mean, I'm excited.
This is a really interesting topic,
but I was deliberately overstating.
- [Rosie] Yeah, I mean, it's pretty cool,
but that is, that does,
that is a perfect example, David,
of what overstatement is.
So we're gonna look at a couple examples
of what writers will do sometimes to,
I would say, both
understatement and overstatement
really help to drive a point home.
We're gonna start with understatement.
So David, you wanna read this sentence?
- [David] Sure.
"So you kidnapped my dog,
"drove to New Orleans
without telling anyone,
"and ate the last cookie
that I was saving?
"Yeah, I'm like, vaguely unhappy."
(Rosie laughs softly)
- [Rosie] This is a horrible
thing that just happened.
So when you said, "Yeah,
I'm like vaguely unhappy,"
after this huge list of horrible things
that this supposed friend has done,
you know, it's clear that,
that you're more than just
a little, vaguely unhappy.
- [David] To be clear, grammarians,
Rosie did not do any of these things.
(Rosie laughs softly)
- [Rosie] Thank you, David.
- [David] This sentence
is a work of fiction.
- [Rosie] Thank you for
letting me off the hook there.
- [David] You're welcome.
So what we're trying to
express in this sentence
is that this is something that should make
the speaker or the writer quite unhappy.
But what we're doing here is
deliberately understating the case
to further drive home the point
that this is actually quite serious.
- [Rosie] Exactly.
- [David] So, ironically,
while the writer is using
minimizing language, saying,
"I am vaguely unhappy,"
or, "like vaguely unhappy,"
which serves to further
qualify that statement,
the fact that they're saying that
after such a litany of sins,
like, the cookie even, that's just ugh!
Really serve to drive
home the opposite effect.
So this is a textbook
example of understatement.
- [Rosie] All right, so we've seen
an example of understatement.
Let's take a look at what an
overstatement might look like.
- [David] "My life is over.
"I got a D on the midterm.
"I am dead; I am literally a skeleton."
- [Rosie] Hooo, wow. (laughs)
So this is a great,
a great example of overstatement.
- [David] So we know
this isn't true, right?
Made a D on your midterm, not great.
But is it truly and actually
the end of someone's life?
No, and this author,
this writer knows that,
knows what they are saying,
because skeletons can't write.
- [Rosie] Exactly.
You might have also heard of hyperbole,
which is what this is.
It's just like, way exaggeration.
But it serves to drive
home this person's point
that they feel really bad
that they got a D on this midterm,
and this is a very effective way
of conveying to us how upset they are,
even though they're not
literally a skeleton,
and they don't think they're
literally a skeleton.
- [David] I think the
emotional impact of this
is much more effective than it would be
if I just said, "I am very upset,
"because I got a D on my midterm."
Like, I think this is more expressive.
And certainly it's not true,
but I think there's an
interesting way to play
with over and understatement
in order to get feelings across.
I think, I think there's
like, a little bit of a taboo
in American English-speaking culture
to too literally say the
state of your emotions,
and so we've discovered
these cultural idioms,
through which we transmit emotion.
So like, compare the
following two examples,
delivered by Rosie.
- [Rosie] 'Kay.
"I'm very angry."
Or, "Yeah, you could
say I'm a little upset."
- [David] Now Rosie is
using understatement
that I think, and I feel that the,
the statement that uses understatement
actually conveys more anger,
because it's more socially
acceptable in the United States
to somewhat publicly
repress your emotions.
- [Rosie] Yeah, exactly.
I mean, you could hear somebody say,
"Yeah, I think I'm
pretty upset about that."
And they're kinda laughing,
but they're upset.
- [David] You can see
the glorious subtlety
of these language techniques.
And I understand, this can
make English a minefield
for people trying to learn the language,
because the subtext of what you're saying,
with overstatement and understatement,
is more important than the text itself.
- [Rosie] Exactly.
- [David] It's very difficult
to learn to interpret those cues.
There are plenty of native speakers
who have trouble with it.
- [Rosie] It's true.
And it's just something that
you can keep an eye out
for when you're reading
and also when you're talking to people.
It may start to, you may
start to spot them more,
as you listen.
- [David] And I suspect that,
if you listen and you study,
I have this sneaking minute suspicion
that you can learn anything.
David, out.
- [Rosie] Rosie, out.
- [David] That was awesome.
- [Rosie] That was fun!